hello I'm gown we're the slow mo guys
and you may have noticed it's the middle
of the night what does that mean that
well usually when we're filming we use
the Sun to light our subject but today
our subject creates its own light so
it's better to do in the dark don't even
need the Sun err because it's Texas in
the summer
we're stood out here at 1:00 in the
morning in shorts and a t-shirt still
sway still sway this video is sponsored
by Google and to help us make it we're
gonna be using the Google pixel 3 a
excel you'll find out more about it in a
bit we've done a video before where I
was spinning wire wool yeah in the night
and I thought how do we escalate that
and I thought we've got two arms but why
stop at two you've also got two legs so
then I thought that's just me spinning
around and there's a machine that does
that already yeah yeah me just going
like this so you found a machine with
four limbs yeah that it's a shop fan
I've hooked up here and taken the
outside off of this is comical and I'll
be honest we have not tested this in the
slightest
no idea if it's gonna work absolutely
not I think we should just plug it in
and see what happens that's probably for
the best
all right it's a dangerous one don't try
this at home what you got safety-wise
well because we're obviously dealing
with sort of burning metal sparks I'm
gonna put this fireproof suit on a fire
resistant suit on to help me protect me
from the heat as well as a balaclava and
some gloves and some goggles so that the
sparks can't find their way to my skin I
said balaclava to an American recently
and they thought it was some kind of
desert do you mean
I will also be in a protective suit
because I'm actually probably more in
the line of fire than you oh yes I will
is gonna be spinning away from me into
you yeah I think I remember last time we
were doing this I was fine and you were
just like this is raining down I'm wet
so first of all downs just gonna spin it
on his hand again like last time there's
a little refresher and I'm gonna use the
pixels nitesite feature because I've
heard it has great low-light capability
for a still almost like a long exposure
so we'll see if I can see him once we
turn this light off
you ready feeling ready I'm feeling
pretty ready alright it's gonna be so
bloody dark it really is oh my god okay
okay go for it
it's lovely still works well yeah it
does look at that that is cool I've
always wanted to get pictures like that
with my phone
anyways I've never been able to it looks
like a I'm a human Catherine Wheel for
this subject as we learned last time we
are going to film it in a slightly
different way to usual with a lower
frame rate and a very high shutter angle
as big as we can get without 359 degrees
so that each frame will be full of
motion blur and those streaks will be as
long as possible if we did a higher
shutter speed 180 like where we usually
are our trails will be cut in half and
if we go all the way up to a thousand
frames a second there won't be trails
there'll be dots you've got like an 80
foot shadow behind you that's pretty
cool alright you ready
turn the light off lights up
whoa you're right Wow who's that good
yeah that look claw did it speed up once
they all flew off yeah
oh that's class Wow you can see the bits
flying off and then landing on stuff
there's no way that I could achieve that
as a person well you don't have enough
on no I don't see as they kept flying
off it was like you can't like moving
around like it was heavier at certain
points then I was like oh god it's like
Walker that bit there's just one
throwing everything there they take
turns then they yeah a little bit
nervous about this one oh me too
you'll be alright well I I'm just
prancing because I can't see anything
you don't to step on any rocks there it
is we're really yeah
oh bloody oh yeah it's like a bunch of
tiny knives
okay bit playback yeah looks like you
got like you leave toys kill you know
yeah this point the camera steady but
goodness said no I was trying to get you
anything I was definitely trying to get
yeah we're so really going for a Dutch
angle here that's what I wanted oh yeah
I was thinking Battlefield Earth it was
a stylistic choice yeah yeah these ones
they're going below camera it's just
peppered me in the crotch area I don't
think I even need safety gear for this
oh look at that whatever blasted the
bottom of the lens play hit the hood I
wonder if I could be under there with
you do you think I'd be alright
oh you'd be fine I mean they're only
danger is these huge globs of thoses
at your legs looking up at you oh that
would work double your I wouldn't it I
would work what is going on I hold it up
like this it's about 3:00 in the morning
and I'm on my back in a quarry ready yep
Oh looks like a pony with a plate of
dude there was a couple of them got away
all the time yeah I'm loving it
there was a couple of sparks that went
down on to you I was watching it's like
I'm showing you from like fireworks
they fit under there it's perfect I
didn't forget any spots on you at all
all going away from me and I'm protected
by the word if something did you run
we're really attracting a lot of bugs
well we've got a huge big light it's
true and there's no moon or any other
light source all right what you gonna do
this time Oh spin it around in all kinds
of directions just go a bit nuts with it
balaclava back on balaclava in that back
on because it's going everywhere
yeah really kicked off at the end
they're miles away look those ones that
everywhere ends up directly coming
towards the camera they end up so big
those real players yeah they're dropping
right in front of it look and then like
some of them I think I aim directly at
you at one point it was just sparks
flying Australia that's cool when it
goes behind you and you're just a
silhouette yeah that is cool I come back
lit by the sparks what about this we'll
take the pics all that Google lovingly
sent us and tape it on to the fan facing
out get a crazy shot sort of POV blade
of all the sparks shooting ours do they
want this phone back or we might be able
to give it back okay well let's try it
yeah bit uh bit wobbly well just lit
around it stayed on the fan I tilted it
down slowly so I could get more of the
the metal foiling it looks like a plain
wing Oh the sound effect is perfect no
an old sci-fi movies where it's like oh
you know go to warp speed all the stars
like that's like from the side window
angle did you hear the rattling of the
[ __ ] ankle that was when it was like
getting up some serious being I think we
got some magnificent looking forward to
there I just have to cool to attention
the fact that you're wearing your safety
gear around your ankles like you're
about to get it well they can't see I
saw before but I peeled off but I'm just
stood in the dread you imagine what it
looks like when a man takes his trousers
off and like puts them on the toilet
looks like that I could get away with it
until you cool it out I think we got
some really nice-looking footage I
really love the dome effect
I made a big difference because usually
I had the one but with this I had four
and I meant the sparks were in all
directions like a solid sheet 360 sheet
of sparks ya thought was wonderful
big old thanks to Google for sponsoring
this video had a lot of fun using the
pixel three Axl I was very impressed by
the nitesite mode I don't know how it
works but it must use stabilization to
take the long exposure I've only ever
done long exposure on tripods because
doing this you'd get this all blurring
the whole thing is somehow stabilizes
one thing I noticed the dark of the
picture is the longer it takes to take
an image so there's some some cool tech
going on that don't know how someone
smarter than you is there's some timing
I also like the fast charging and I
plugged it in when we first got it it
told me how long it was gonna take and
it said charging rapidly or charging far
and it was just super quick we've got a
second channel subscribe to that one
subscribe to this one there's a bell hit
us up on the socials anything else yeah
I'm gonna start trying to fill up Google
and just I'm taking pictures and
recording everything we'll see you in
the next video